demi lovato debuts a giant new tattoo
after completing a stint in rehab with a
source telling et they wanted to get
back on track and start the new year off
on the right foot i'm in a new chapter
in my life the sorry not sorry singer
revealed the new ink over the weekend on
their instagram stories that's demi
rocking a huge black spider on the side
of their head the artist behind demi's
body art celebrity tattoo artist dr wu
who shared a glimpse of the design on
his insta story too he's also the same
artist who tatted lyrics from the group
beautiful chorus song infinite universe
on demi's hand back in august in a video
the singer posted you can see demi
shaved off a chunk of their buzz cut
hairstyle to make room for the spider
tap the 29 year old also explains the
meaning behind the design writing on
their instagram story quote it was
grandmother spider who taught us many
things she taught us about pottery and
weaving she taught us about fire and
light and dark she taught us that we are
all connected on the web each one of us
having our own place in this world this
new tattoo comes after a source tells
e.t that demi completed a rehab stint in
utah recently and is now back home in la
the source explains quote they wanted to
get back on track and recently swore off
being california sober demi's friends
and family were there to support them
during their time in rehab they wanted
to start the year off on a good path and
this stay helped them with this back in
december the former disney star declared
they were no longer quote california
sober a term used to describe someone
who uses drugs and alcohol in moderation
it's a topic demi opened up about in
march during an interview with cbs this
morning i i think the term that i best
identify with is california sober i
really don't feel comfortable
explaining the parameters of my recovery
to people
because i don't want anyone to look at
my parameters
of safety and think that's what works
for them
or because it might not
i
am cautious to say that
just like
i feel
the complete abstinent method isn't like
a one-size-fits-all solution for
everybody i don't think that
this journey of moderation is a
one-size-fits-all solution for everybody
too but by december demi wrote on their
insta story i no longer support my
california sober ways sober sober is the
only way to be actually anything i lay
it all out on the line and i'm very very
honest and back in 2017 the triple
threat shared why they've been so honest
with their sobriety journey
i had a few moments in my life where i
decided i wanted to change you know i've
done a lot of growing and so it wasn't
like one pivotal moment that i decided
to change i think when i went into
treatment i decided to talk about the
reasons why i was in treatment and then
and that was when i was 18 when i was 19
i had a moment where i knew that i
needed to get sober and so that was
another pivotal moment and then there's
just been growing since then that i've
decided you know i it's time to be even
more honest with my fans and share
things with them so i don't think it's
one specific moment but i've definitely
had a few where i've realized i need to
make some changes in my life